rentrée des classes égale fin des
vacances égalent des plages qui se
vident et des vacanciers de septembre
qui pourront profiter du beau temps et
du calme revenu reportage sur la côte
d'azur aujourd'hui sandra smit didier
beaumont
le tempo s'est ralenti la fièvre de
l'été retombe les plages d'antibes ou de
juan-les-pins prennent leurs quartiers
de basse saison la fréquentation
touristique est en chute libre
certains observateurs basée à des postes
stratégiques
le confirme aujourd'hui c'est ma y
arrive du monde encore sur la plage là
et jusque là dans le coin c'est 10
heures tout finit pas tout à fait les
plages et les snacks ne ferme pas avant
le 30 septembre
mais les rideaux sont tirés dans la
majorité des appartements d'été une
nouvelle clientèle investi les lieux
pendant que certains préparent les
cartables d'autres savoure cette arrière
saison
c'est excellent c'est bien c'est un peu
30 fois la mer mais c'est bien beaucoup
plus agréable au profit de tous et on
est content qu'il ya des millions de
gens qui nous envient la comprends qu'on
peut prendre aussi des problèmes on
n'emprunte pas d'ailleurs plus assez de
clients certains commerçants ont déjà
fait leurs valises d'autres comptent les
jours avec des projets de femmes saison
je vais gagner au loto et parti rose
hill au farniente total
mais pas besoin de partir si loin le
tempo du mois de septembre se prête à la
douceur de vivre pour les autres ce
n'était qu'une petite carte postale pour
vous souhaiter une excellente rentrée